Alright, now let's say we have a bunch of our
data in a relational database. Your next question is probably,
how do we get it out? And what can we
do with it? Well, let's try to learn about this
using our aadhaar data. Now, data is usually retrieved from
a relational database using one of a family of languages
that I'll call SQL like languages. Well, there are some
small variations between the languages. They have the same general
concepts and syntax. Now, how could we query
the Aadhaar enrollment data set with SQL like syntax,
if data was in a database. Stored in a
table called Aadhaar data. Well, the most simple thing
that we might want to do is simply to select all of the data, that is, all rows
and columns. If we wanted to do that, we
could type something like select star from aadhaar data.
Note that the SQL syntax is pretty human readable. We're
just saying we want to select star or everything from
the aadhaar data table. If we were to run this
command as is, we would produce tens of thousands of rows
which is probably not super constructive right now. So what
we can do is, limit the number of rows by just
saying limit 20 at the end of our SQL command.
If we ran this query, let's see what we get back.
Oh, great, the first 20 rows of
the data. These are rows describing enrollments for
the registrar Allahabad Bank, with various enrollment agencies,
districts, age, genders, et cetera. Now, say we
only wanted some of these columns. Say,
district and subdistrict. We could just ask for
those specific columns instead of star. For example,
we might write, select district, subdistrict from aadhaar
data, limit 20.